this is actually one of my favorite
things to give away it's like secret and
dirty cuz how good it is I think you get
so much Goodwill giving away something
that people know cost you something you
get so much persuasive power as a result
of giving that give that you get a
disproportionate amount of people who
want to work with you you do work for
free ir and gy owners ads for free for
30 days I'll run the ads for free I'll
get you leads for free to show you I
know what I'm doing what happens after
you get leads for free you make some
money what happens when you make some
money you want to keep making money ah
in exchange for continuing to make money
I would like to make some of it as well
simple offer